what makes your writing different what
stands out and we were talking about it
today a bunch of us and I was thinking
you really get your characters to to
happen they fight they fight yeah
there's a lot of combat a lot of verbal
combat in your script
I grew up everyone else in my family
smarter than I am and all of my friends
growing up were smarter than I was and I
really enjoyed the sound of them arguing
with each other yes and I guess I was
the mascot or something I'm not exactly
sure why I was loud to hang out with my
friends or my family yeah but I grew up
really enjoying the sound of a good
argument of smart people arguing and I
just wanted to imitate that sound you
know it's incredible I was thinking
about it today you must be very
impossible to have an argument with
because you write such fantastic
arguments back and forth it's like it's
like a ping-pong match no think having
an argument with you I would I would get
destroyed no you would not I would
surrender instantly I I fold like a
cheap thing that you know that folds
really easy man no one writes like you
great things where you you really do
your none your non-confrontational no
I'm Mike GPS is permanently set to the
path of least resistance yes that's good
that's good in fact you're gonna show a
clip from Steve Jobs yeah and I was
prepared to have a big argument with the
studio today because I thought it was
the wrong clip to show in the context of
the movie it's a very good scene it's a
very emotional scene out of context it's
not quite as exciting as he as you'd
want for the Conan O'Brien show right so
I really worked myself up into a lather
and I called the studio and I think I
was talking to an intern who said no we
really liked the clip and I said me too
you're also you're a very I've heard
that you're a very physical writer and
that makes sense to me because whenever
I'm watching your work I can sense you
when you're writing it you're not just
quietly on I am I've got an iPad you're
up and jumping around you're very
physical when I'm riding on playing all
the parts I once broke my nose when I
was writing because it it was a scene
where you know somebody was doing one of
these comedy lunges I'm gonna kill you
while somebody else held him back one of
those things right and I was really
excited about it and and I wound up in
the bathroom mirror doing it and I
lunged right into the mirror with nobody
holding me back and if it had been a
Scorsese film he would have said let's
go again this time a little less blood
blood everywhere that's fantastic I love
that and anyone who saw you later on
when you're all bandaged up what
happened I was writing yeah
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography